DEAN HILDEBRAND: Hello.
Today we're going to give a
peek behind the VM's you launch
on Google Cloud into our
storage infrastructure.
My name is Dean
Hildebrand, and I'm
a technical director for
storage in the Google Cloud
office of the CTO.
DENIS SERENYI: And
I'm Denis Serenyi.
I'm the tech lead for
Google Cloud Storage.
DEAN HILDEBRAND: All right.
So in this session,
we're going to answer
a very simple question--
how does Google Cloud scale
your storage infrastructure?
And it actually has a
relatively simple answer.
So the first key
point, and I really
do think this is a
very important point,
is that there is a single
infrastructure that
underpins both Google
services and Google Cloud.
And so Google Cloud
customers, and YouTube,
and [? Android ?] Play
Store services scale
for the exact same
reason, and that's
because they're using the exact
same underlying infrastructure.
And next, we're going to dive
into the details of Colossus,
the file system that is at
the core of this scalability
and talk about how Colossus
abstracts out the complexities
and messiness of the
physical infrastructure
to provide a highly-performant,
cost-efficient storage
infrastructure for Google
Cloud's storage services.
So let's take a step back.
What are Cloud regions?
With 23 regions and 70 zones
working together so seamlessly,
it's sometimes easy to forget
they're actually mapped down
to a set of groups of
physical data centers,
and what's in
these data centers?
Pipes.
Lots of pipes?
But actually, OK, there's
a little more as well.
There's also lots of
servers and storage,
because how else are you
going to compute anything?
So it's pretty straightforward,
though, that when
you launch a VM, let's
say, a 32 VCPU skylight
ends up running on one
of our skylight machines.
And the operation of this
is pretty fascinating,
but one of the questions
I get a lot from customers
is, how does our storage work?
How does Google Cloud take
our servers, disks, networks,
and cobble them all together
to provide such a wide range
of storage services?
And a typical follow-up
question is, does Google
use the same infrastructure
as Google Cloud?
And of course, the answer is
yes, but how does this work?
So let's cover that as well.
So in this talk, we wanted
to give a peek behind the VM
that you're launching to give
some insight into how we build
our storage systems
here at Google
so you can have the confidence
that your applications
on Google Cloud can scale
just like Google services.
So, to begin, just like any
well-designed software system,
all of Google is layered
with a common set
of scalable services.
There are three
core building blocks
used by each of our
storage services
and they are Colossus,
Spanner, and Borg.
And then, of course,
there's many others,
but in the interest of time,
let's focus on these big three.
So first we have Borg,
which launches everything
from compute services
to storage services
and everything in between.
And as probably many
of you already know,
much of the learnings
inside of Borg
was all translated into
Kubernetes when it launched.
Second, we have
Spanner, which is
our globally-consistent
scalable database that
is used by Google services as
well as our Cloud customers
as Cloud Spanner.
And finally, we have
Colossus, the beginnings
of which started
as the Google file
system which inspired
many open source file
systems such as HDFS.
But since that time,
Google has scaled a lot,
and there is a lot
more data to store.
And so the need for this
higher level of scalability
really drove the
creation of Colossus.
And since this is a
talk about storage,
Dennis is going to go deep
into the details of Colossus
in a few moments.
And so to get back to
this question of how
does Google Cloud
operate our storage,
it uses these three
core building blocks
to provide the underpinnings
for all of the storage services
that you see from
Firestore, to Cloud SQL,
to Filestore, and
Google Cloud Storage.
Now, let's also get
back to the question
of whether Google uses
the same infrastructure,
and how does it use it?
And the answer, of
course, is that, yes,
it does, as I've stated already.
And it does it in a pretty
simple way, in the same way
that the Cloud does it.
It takes each of the
services that you
see, from YouTube to Photos--
takes these same scalable
building blocks and then layers
on top of all of
their needs to provide
the level of availability,
performance, durability
that you're looking for
in your storage systems.
So this allows both Google
services and Google Cloud
customers to scale
in the exact same way
because they're using the exact
same set of building blocks.
And so you can have the
confidence that if you go off
and watch Cobra Kai and there's
also a million other people
that want to watch Cobra
Kai at the same time,
then these three services
are behind the scenes scaling
to meet the needs.
And traditionally,
what's interesting
is that much of the use
cases into Borg, Spanner,
and Colossus, and all of
the innovation in them
was driven by the
Google services.
But as our Cloud customers have
really scaled across the globe,
they are now providing a lot
of the innovation as well.
So let's look at a typical flow.
Let's say user
launches a GKE cluster
on to a series of servers.
So the VMs in that cluster
get launched on to a series
of the servers that
they requested--
and that's using
Borg, by the way--
and so then these VMs running
on those services in the GKE
cluster access their
favorite storage services.
Let's say they use Persistent
Disk for their boot volume,
and then they used Filestore
and Google Cloud Storage
for their unstructured data.
Once they start
accessing those services,
the exact same big
three building blocks--
Colossus, Spanner, and Borg--
are underneath the covers
providing all of the services.
So Borg is provisioning the
resources for that storage
system, Spanner is
storing the metadata,
to say, for example,
who can access the data
and where is the data
actually located,
and then Colossus, of
course, is providing
all storage for the data.
So now that we understand
these three basic services,
for the rest of this talk, let's
deep-dive into Cloud Storage
and how it makes
use of Colossus.
So from the user
point of view, Google
has spent a lot
of time and effort
to try to make Cloud Storage
as easy to use as possible.
We want it to be as easy as
filling up and emptying out
an actual bucket.
But behind the scenes,
from Google's perspective,
Cloud Storage is actually a
massive distributed system
that has the potential
to take advantage
of all of our regions,
networks, points of presence,
and all the servers and disks
that I talked about earlier.
And it has to make use
of all those aspects
to satisfy three
primary use cases--
content storage,
compute analytics,
and machine learning, as
well as backup and archive.
And from the Cloud
perspective, we
have lots of customers
in each of these areas
that are scaling,
using the services.
So, for example, box is
delivering a lot of content
to its users, the
Broad Institute
is constantly analyzing lots
of different genomes every day,
and The New York Times, you
can find a really interesting
article about how it's using
Google Cloud Storage to archive
its entire photo history.
But Google Cloud
Storage can scale
to meet these needs
because it's already
been meeting the needs of our
services such as YouTube, ads,
and photos, which
archives a lot of photos.
So in this talk, we've
learned about how Colossus
is underpinning
Google Cloud Storage,
and it provides support for
three very unique use cases.
And now I'm going
to turn it over
to Denis so he can
explain, how does Colossus
achieve all of this?
DENIS SERENYI: Thanks, Dean.
So we talk a lot
about GCS and how
it can support a very
wide range of use cases
from archival storage to
high throughput analytics,
but we don't talk a lot
about the system that lies
under GCS, Colossus,
which enables
GCS's unique capabilities.
So I'm going to dive
into the details
of how GCS uses Colossus
and how Colossus works.
We'll start from the top
and work our way down.
So I'm starting with the
client library which is how
GCS interacts with Colossus.
Actually, the client is
probably the most complex part
of the system.
There's a lot of functionality
that goes directly in there,
for instance, software
RAID, and applications
can choose their
own encodings based
on application requirements.
Applications built on top
of Colossus, such as GCS,
use a variety of encodings to
fine tune the performance cost
trade-offs that they need to
make for different workloads.
The foundation of Colossus is
its scalable metadata service
called the curator.
It scales because clients
talk to it only for control
operations-- for instance,
creating a file--
and because it can
scale out horizontally.
It can also scale
massively because it's
built on top of a NoSQL
database like Bigtable.
In fact, the original
motive Google
had for building
Colossus was that search
was running into scaling
limits, as Dean mentioned,
of its predecessor,
the Google file system.
Putting file system
metadata into Bigtable
was the key trick
that allowed Colossus
to scale up by over 100x over
the largest DFS clusters.
Another way the system
scales is that Colossus
minimizes the number of hops
for data on the network.
Data flows directly
between D servers,
which our really
not very clever name
for our simple network, detach
disks and the Colossus client.
Finally, Colossus includes
background storage managers
called custodians
which handle things
like disk space balancing
and RAID reconstruction.
They play a key role in
maintaining the durability
and availability of data as well
as ensuring the storage system
is working efficiently.
So that's Colossus
in a nutshell.
Here's a picture of
what a typical Google
cluster looks like.
The key ingredient is having
the shared storage pool managed
by the Colossus control plane.
This large, disaggregated
storage layer
is able to support a wide
variety of applications
on the same underlying
physical resources
and each application
has the rough illusion
of having an
isolated file system.
In aggregate, we're talking
about really big scale here.
A single cluster is scalable
to the exabytes of storage
with tens of
thousands of machines.
And what I've drawn here
represents a typical mix
of internal Google services.
You've got some YouTube serving
and maybe some Ads MapReduces.
Together with GCP VM instances,
using GCS, altogether
sharing the same underlying
Colossus file system.
So it's really the case that
the same storage system that's
driving these
global scale Google
applications is also driving
our customers' Cloud workloads.
The scale desegregation
of resources and variety
of workloads is the key to
driving efficiency and lowering
costs.
For instance, we can
provision to the peak demand
of low latency workloads, like
maybe this YouTube serving
workload here, and then
run batch workloads
like MapReduces
and other analytics
more cheaply by having them
fill in the gaps of otherwise
idle time.
Another great thing
about Colossus
is it abstracts away
a ton of complexity
that storage intensive
applications would otherwise
have to deal with.
For one thing, frankly,
our data centers
have a tremendous variety of
underlying storage hardware.
When we're adding
capacity to the system,
we're always buying the
disk of the day, which
is whatever disk
currently has the lowest
total cost of ownership,
and the same goes for flash.
And these devices
last a long time,
which means that each cluster
will have many disk sizes
and types.
Add to that the fact
that applications
have different requirements
around durability,
availability, and latency.
Colossus addresses that
by providing service tiers
and allowing applications to
specify erasure codes tuned
to their needs.
And add to that,
at Google scale,
some hardware is failing
virtually all the time.
That's just a testament to the
scale that we're operating at.
It's not like the
hardware is unreliable,
it's just that there
is a lot of it.
So dealing with some
failures is the common case.
Colossus steers IO
around these failures
and does fast
background recovery
to provide highly durable
storage within the cluster
despite all of this chaos.
The end result is that for
GCS as well as Google's
own services, these
hardware resources
and their associated complexity
are totally abstracted away.
Systems provision bytes and IO
as abstract, undifferentiated
units.
That makes using storage very
simple for all the applications
we're running.
So now, let's deep-dive
into how Colossus
helps ensure the storage pool
is being managed efficiently.
I mentioned that applications
built on top of Colossus can
provision bytes in IO
as abstract resources,
but as you might imagine,
it involves a lot of magic
to ensure that all the
IO and all the bytes
are available when
applications need them,
but also not over-provision
either of these things,
because that would
mean a lot of waste.
Under the hood, we take
advantage of the fact
that data has a wide variety
of temperatures as we're
trying to illustrate here.
We mix in flash, not always
to lower latency, but simply
because flash is the
most efficient way
to serve really hot data.
If we do our job right,
we buy just enough
flash to push the IO density per
gigabyte for the remaining data
into the range that
can be served by disks,
and then we buy
just enough disks
so that we can fill them all up.
If we do this well and
have the right mix,
we end up with really
efficient storage.
Now let's talk
about how Colossus
maximizes storage efficiency
for disk-based storage.
Within our population of
disks, as I mentioned earlier,
we're going to have a wide
variety of disk sizes.
To maximize efficiency we'll
want to do two things--
we'll want to keep
the disks full,
because empty bytes are
just excess inventory,
and we want to keep
the disks busy,
so we're not wasting
that disk spindle.
Because each cluster has
roughly the same IO bandwidth,
what this means is that--
sorry, because each disk
has roughly the same IO
bandwidth, what this
means is that we'll
have to keep hotter
data evenly spread
across all the drives
in the cluster,
and then we just fill up
all the remaining space
on each drive with cold bytes.
To make this work,
the key problem
that Colossus has solved is
placing data intelligently.
Turns out, newly written
data is typically hotter,
so Colossus spreads new writes
evenly across all the disks,
leading to a pretty even
balance of hot data.
And then Colossus's his
background rebalancer
moves older, cold
data to bigger drives.
This works great for
analytics workloads,
because analytics data
typically cools off as it ages.
Now, a lot of this stuff
was developed and refined
over the years so that Google
can run its own services--
search ads, YouTube, et
cetera, all those services
that Dean was talking about--
at massive scale, as simply
and efficiently as possible.
But for Cloud, this means
that Cloud users can also
leverage this functionality,
and you end up
with simple and
inexpensive storage.
OK, so this is a picture of
one of our internal dashboards
used to monitor
and debug storage
performance in a cluster.
There's a lot of boxes
in this visualization.
Each of those small
boxes is a D server,
and their sized by disk
capacity and colored
by spindle utilization.
When it looks like,
this we're really happy.
Basically, the whole
cluster is really busy--
that's why it's looking
all red like that--
so we're getting all the value
out of our disk spindles.
Sure, there's some darker
colors sprinkled in there,
but it turns out those
are D servers that
are down for maintenance
or being decommissioned.
So that's Colossus
in a nutshell.
Now, let's pop the stack, and
talk about GCS itself, which
is really just a layer on top.
It turns out, GCS is employing
a lot of the same tricks
that Colossus uses, just at the
region and multi-region level.
To illustrate how
they're similar, here's
a simple representation
of a GCS deployment in one
of our GCP regions.
In this example, we've
got three clusters,
each with a GCS instance
on top of Colossus storage.
First off, GCS employs some
of the same hot data placement
techniques used by Colossus--
placing data close to where
it's likely to be read
and also caching data
to minimize network
distance and lower latency.
And just like Colossus is
rebalancing colder data
within the cluster, GCS
rebalances colder data
between clusters in
the region to make
sure we're able to fully
utilize all available space
as well as ensuring that data
is always durable and available
in the face of
disruptions or failures
in the underlying
infrastructure.
GCS kind of thinks of each
cluster in Google's fleet
as an abstract disk, and
by managing these clusters
intelligently,
it's able to handle
all the diverse workloads
that users bring to GCS,
like content serving in
archival and analytics,
and do it efficiently.
The way we think of GCS is that
it's Colossus in the Cloud.
So to wrap up, we know
about GCP's scalability.
What we uncovered
today is that GCP
can scale because it's built
on top of these core Google
services that are
battle tested and have
demonstrated the ability to
scale to pretty massive levels.
In fact, GCS is just a
layer on top of Colossus,
which is the cluster level
file system that doesn't just
handle the storage needs of GCE
VMs, GCS content serving, et
cetera, but also handles all of
Google's internal storage needs
from Search, to Maps,
YouTube, photos, et cetera.
And lastly, we learn that
there is a ton of complexity
under the covers of GCP,
but systems like Colossus
have abstracted
all of that away,
allowing GCP customers to
just focus on their business.
So to wrap up, I want to
give a big thanks to Dean
for being my partner in
crime for this deep-dive
into what lies under the
hood of storage at GCP.
DEAN: Hey, Denis, glad to be
that partner, and thanks a ton
for sharing your extremely
deep knowledge in Colossus
and Google Cloud
Storage, and I really
hope this gives our
customers confidence that,
by using this underlying
scalable infrastructure,
that they can scale their
applications as big as they're
looking for.
DENIS: Thanks a lot.
I hope you found this
as interesting as we do
and that you learned a lot.
Have a great day.